now before the pandemic the italian city
of venice was overrun with tourists so
much so that it was looking for ways to
restrict their numbers
now though it has the opposite problem
empty streets and waterways in a city
that very much depends on tourism
revenue
dw's max zander reports on how venice is
looking to strike the right balance as
it reopens for business
a gondola ride is probably the most
romantic experience you can have here in
venice
even for veteran gondolier maurizio
carloto
when we take someone with us we try to
make them live the dream
he is one of the city's roughly 600
gonorrheas
usually carlotto will do three tours a
day but the pandemic has practically
run him out of business from october to
now
i've only done one ride this city just
came out of a lockdown
but saint mark's square is still eerily
quiet
the world famous cafe florian remains
closed during the week
over the years venice became almost
entirely dependent on tourism
and the pandemic with its travel
restrictions and lockdowns
further laid bare the issue these cafes
here
once popular tourist destinations are
now closed due to a lack of customers
but now there seems to be some light at
the end of the tunnel though nobody
really knows
how exactly and when tourism will
restart
some have hopes that a new start will
bring changes
david bozzaro is an activist with
vanessa.com
the group installed this counter in the
windowva pharmacy
to help publicize the declining number
of residents
50 965 is the actual number of
people citizens living today here in
venice
that's 30 people less than a week before
overtourism has been driving people out
of the city but the problem is more
complicated than that
you know it's a very strange situation
we don't want too much tourism because
it would
suffocate the place but at the same time
we can't live without tourism
in a place where everyone lives off
tourism one way or another
it is difficult to find a balance the
city's tourism counselor says
the situation is not unique to venice
but rather
venice is in need of a unique solution
venice has not been sold out in a
derogatory sense
all tourist cities have experienced the
last few years
in the absence of rules to protect
certain segments of the city
as a first step the city has begun to
closely monitor visitor numbers
starting next year tourists will have to
pay a fee to enter the city
but maurizio carlotto misses what some
people consider
the bad old days
i would also go back to what it was like
two years ago
with a few less people maybe but it
wasn't a massacre like they were saying
it was sustainable
the debate over the future of tourism in
venice is far from over
but for now most people here cannot wait
for visitors to return